and we're gonna get ready of course with
our next matches here in Group B but in
the meantime let's see where we're at
right now I mean it's been quite a
battle for a lot of the players that are
here right now double is in the lead
here in our group but again there are
three players tied up
yes it's very yes this is like familiar
it's very familiar because it I really
feel like gonna come down to the matches
and if you guys are just tuning in it's
very important every match that happens
because if you went to oh and 2-1 it can
make them make all the difference oh
yeah they make every single difference
and right now we're gonna have one of
those matches that's gonna be pivotal
here to see how the groups are gonna be
placing right now we have a bell from
Peru versus super Akuma from France yes
and knock I was mentioning you know Abel
did come to Europe and he was here for a
while I think he was staying in Spain
yeah you went to four versus fighting
was it olq oh yeah yeah and I mean a lot
of people were beating him in Europe I
think they just used to their lives
matter but recently that those eliezer
players haven't been coming out yeah but
this is a matter we rarely see yeah we
see Europe a lot maybe not here but this
is gonna be good Aliza versus Akuma
we're gonna start bringing them to new
terms and yes air to air let's go Europe
versus Peru
I wonder if superhuman knows the changes
that allies are going to get a lot of
changes to her strings yeah I mean I
feel like you were one of those
characters that can kind of thread the
needle especially with certain tools
that has like the low jab the down one
too and of course the down too
especially will come up with be knows
what did a back - yeah yeah that's the
DP is one to talk about as well because
I feel like it was a very good auntie
option as well yeah she's definitely
probably the character that's most
notorious for taking to the skies yeah
did you see that when he went to become
at the demon playful I thought the
master dashed forward because that's a
really good way to get to Cooper's back
yeah
it's something that I thought about when
I was in Pakistan which I haven't seen
from a long time so you mentioned a lot
of guys being either trying to duck
underneath just kind of mitigate the big
suppress right yes
all right here we go gets the follow up
here with the big combo - jab see G&S
yeah he messed up one of his - tabs and
it kills a couple of ability Oh in
spring it's very tight to at least
maximize and be able to do the 4 jabs
into the four core - yeah you gotta be
on point
that's almost spray perfect right there
yeah I felt was rage now nice that was
so sick anti-air but was the aerial I
feel like he was it's enough though it's
enough it's enough
yeah he definitely was aerial but it's
okay it was enough to kill him the most
- quick round tack I was able to get the
dive kick here down for I want to see if
this dive kick against each other all
the time kick there's a game for that
right dr. Cashion alright the follow up
here list you there's the fireball
Amen I like the patience here for my
belly belly just waiting yeah he's quite
happy to sit back and just try to punish
to prefer phrase mistakes see look he's
just back - he trying to keep him away
out of the range of down three which is
key
yeah which is key he does not want to
deal with the damage big something he
got hit by a once earlier makes it very
very open for an Akuma player if you're
staying out of that range of down three
I mean yeah he has to deal with that I
mean the 2d style jump and that's
something that only a few characters
have in this game ever look at this
though the standing - into firewalkers
before come on this should be dead with
the right palm ball super kumar on the
board my staff is there he had to use
some meter but he was able to build up a
good amount as well yes still close so
far very red close go to the suite
that's what I want to see - idea
sometimes you gotta make these big reeds
and go for these risks here look at this
damage let's see what he gets
mix up Oh Oh big nice block dodd kick
that's frustrating as what goes for the
podcast dude - season 300 count hit
didn't finish it though yeah good I had
a chance there geez head oh my god yes
confident in how he's using it now oh
she does a double jump she was in the
end night long super kuma taking it to a
final round now just like that he's
eating it up here uh-huh
looking much better little more
confidence in his ability to get inside
all right oh the steak you can't miss
the lose a big immediate what probably
one of the most damaging launches that
she has yeah
and just lost in there yeah huge missing
put on the dive cake and Akuma having
meter here this is gonna be problematic
one he could end it oh my god the chop
did jump it's at Oh have you got wolvox
yeah it's gonna hurt it's not gonna kill
what's the mix-up one more hit boy be
careful what just happened oh the count
three I bailed does my stroke taking the
best match I like how he put the
pressure on himself he made the right
readeth and he didn't want to have to
react defensively every they were both
with little life left yeah but I felt
put it on himself to be able to take the
advantage of the initiative in the
matchup and able to take that first
matchup absolutely every match counts
from here on out remember there is a
game differential these guys have to
make sure they get the biggest lead
possible right now kuma a superhuman
just think about getting that W now I
thought the master would love to have a
to O'Hare what's gonna do here Ford Ford
for something that we rarely seen here
from super Akuma Elise in his uh in his
the gameplay in these matchups yeah
you're looking for that down three
mostly but he's trying to get him to
rage like you said he's finding it hard
right now because I post movement is
being really really red oh it's also the
viable to talk waves
all right nice big damage here puts him
at the range again it put up off-axis
and look at this he's gonna have an
opportunity at the wall mix up once more
he could do it he has range art
beautiful patient staff from about oh my
gosh he bet the farm on that one good
block nice now Ford when it's erupting
he has a chance with the load jab able
to snipe it out look at it a bell
continuing is Lee near crazy super puma
he's in trouble but he starts off the
next round with a down three clean hey
can't you take it to one I finish the
combo nice very good gets the wall here
goes through the mix-up and of course
the paces from they'll not do we detect
group that was a sick punish to to into
the X / oh oh here we go
this bit goes for the power crush super
come we're looking together the score
port Oh what interrupt no pizza for a
bell oh he's in a bad position does he
even need it
oh man this is not looking good deal
with that the opportunity for a charge
use that meter 10 meter SuperDuper
awesome OPP I love it but man this is uh
this is the Porticus right now he has no
meter he's gonna have to be very careful
one for the nosebleed side gets a
follow-up here that's gonna get to the
wall once the mix-up here hey I felt now
sniffing blood he smelled it the husband
also might yeah it's that weird ease
wearing its the camo either she doesn't
like okay
even for the pressure head have you
going that dive cakes no the monster has
a massive life he doesn't want to commit
to anything stupid not overextend Oh
they trade that was a big opportunity
was deep enough to the wall not in place
that was a bull by food but the wool
wasn't that what we'll hit that down for
sweep super Kimmel one dragged away
evening up the set and he finish it
though no Falls let me talk either side
man the belief in that downpour at the
very end man that could have been that
could have ended his round yeah but it's
such a good option but because it has
tracking a pork side yeah have you got
off I mean you didn't have to put the
corners well right now super Akuma to
round someone looking to tie it up here
but a bell trying to try to get out of
the corner use that meter all of it
there's the power crush again he's hit
every single power crush and still gets
a combo yeah but it doesn't match on
super cube I will take the match and
that really is the strength of Akuma
like even if you don't land your compost
you're gonna have the right Oki in the
right distance at the wall to make the
moves that count two down three the jabs
is down to make those clean and you can
convert into even more damage yeah that
was that's that vegan stage though they
caused a lot of issues there for able
when you try to over is okey luck for is
down for three he went to the other side
happen twice you know it has very Wiggly
shape rules ice as very big as most hard
to find the woman you to Zambia walls
man sometimes it's sometimes they're not
the most sturdy of walls right damn
walkers all right let's see here we're
going to a pivotal match a final match
between these two and we're taking it to
a violent system yes this is a
conventional stage head nothing crazy
let's go final match who's gonna take it
winner of this will be placed in second
place currently nice and again you know
the good thing about the power crush is
obviously it's a new broom is law so if
you're already used to it but ask
evasion cuz he kind of goes it's like a
little mini backs way right yeah not
only that it's us it's a big because I
mean this power crush normally is a high
right
and know that it gets a wall spot -
which is huge that's very good
he'll punish my ascetical super Akuma
takes the lead in the sack
super super wad bought Mita on both
sites oh he had the jumping man they're
going all over the place he jumped to
the mid option there he's happy to care
ply we utilize that too because super
cool could eat that one up and hit a
counter hit power crush or just a level
2 power crush that that's gonna be the
end oh don't try to die kick on me
I love how a book jumps back and tries
lady confirms the whip that goes for the
ax dive kick is so good again having
each other gets the wall here this could
be big looking super Coopers
sidestepping into the foreground
especially for the position oh nice I
like it but no cheese now not in time
Rach available and almost two balls of
me up how's he gonna deal with it all
the low jab yeah ain't gonna deal with
the heavy go what about your piece 1
round 2 piece hair perú presses prods is
it that boss battles or I'll a tile a
looking famous right now here in this
round
nice able to get the splat not able to
get any additional damage again you
can't get it closer to this we are here
tied up in the final match between these
two right now super koopa working that
magic
and he has meter still what's he gonna
do old man to pick up you better tech
nice jump I like you got output
oh that's combo that was sick
good luck that was really good right now
super Akuma on the verge of getting
another point on the scoreboard again so
much confidence in that power crush do
wrong punish oh here we go
look on the downfall can't use that too
much edit look punishable super giver
can you find the wall yes four four two
one hasn't met the wall what's the mix
of hell oh that might be it it should be
it can you finish eggs one wakes up to
go that is gonna be it crazy super Akuma
already office sees with the handshake
will take the match over a belt of ice
road and move into second place at the
moment top stuff and yeah these guys
taking it to the final parts of the set
of course the final match there yep but
the explosive nature of Akuma just
proved to be too much for Elijah there
yeah like I said super kuma has
qualified for every second world tour
there's been 2017-2018 last year but he
hasn't got out the group stage this is
his best chance right now he got the
winner booked a coma now got do another
about the maestro he is 2 & 1 at the
moment in this pool yeah only Anakin
early on yes and I think Anakin will be
coming up next right now versus you are
you double this is gonna be a very
important match oh yeah I mean this one
is kind of like what I believe to be
like you know the unstoppable force
versus the immovable object and I feel
like double obviously with the character
matchup I mean law obviously has the
advantage speed wise right yeah a lot of
folks in his favor a lot of options even
to beat you know a lot of jacks lows yes
so that's gonna obviously come into play
matchup wise but Anakin is one of those
players where he is just a master of
spacing so it's gonna really come down
to who's equal to get the advantage
mentally and who's able to put the
pressure on their opponent yeah so even
if on paper law is good versus Jack
because of his pressure and his
punishment it doesn't matter him when
you look at the results the results
speak for themselves Anakin's done so
well through this year and every
tournament is gone too and he's just
been using Jack you know he's a
character specialist yeah so you know
this is this is not gonna be one of
those cases where we could just look at
paper and say oh Lord goodness is Jackie
O that was more likely to win that's a
pistol Anakin a truce to
the game you know even though he is a
character specialist he he makes it an
attempt to learn the players learned the
characters he mentioned that I mean in
his interview as well yeah he is
prepared or trying to be prepared for
everybody that comes away key matchups
he's done is over that's a beautiful
thing about Tekken as well is that you
can pick a character be a kindness
machinist and put your own stamp on that
character right so it's really race but
before we get it as much some words from
double by this tournament
start off by listening okay to create a
flawless total is Allah in Quran dad
while he got his wish he feels like Jack
seven is a good match room he's probably
got one of the best Jack's if not the
best Jack in the world and he's gonna
have to face his I guess he gets his
wish right yeah this is everything you
asked for man you want to play Jack play
who else but Red Bull ratings Anakin up
on the stage right now and like we said
before I mean Luke is a good match up on
paper versus Jack but I'm wondering if
he's talking about it on a corner on a
paper thing or a practical thing yeah
because you have strong Shar Peis in
Japan as well or maybe he just likes
fighting Jack in general who knows
anyways we're gonna go into the matchup
here in five
all right I don't think this is what he
just got popped up the head right now
you utilizing some of the folks here
you'd be pretty funny this is a bluff
but I don't want to say but I want to
wish it into existence
I had to follow up here it's looking uh
he's what he's actually using these
counter pokes pretty well but he scooped
him out of the running slash kick area
nanak and looking to close it out here
yeah he'd like to take that the jack
player huh what'd you wish for
damn out of all the things to say
perfect timing shout out to the
production team I was amazing
there we go doubled object yeah yet the
war was here to go forth junkyard you
put a couple simple yeah keeping him
there let's see what he does the sides
of this is worth gonna get dangerous and
very very hairy I mean I'm sure Anakin
has been paying attention to how doubles
was playing as well yeah uh-huh
you say the throw just a switch position
that jack has a really good pose for
that the sidestep attack the follow up
here Anakin looking really good all the
dog don't even tried the defense on this
man Anakin man just just - top in - wait
he knew that top was gonna throw some
analogy did you say would be funny
people to blow up man this is this is
scary I don't want her crush anyone's
dreams at pool boy I don't bother up
heavy go finally goes for the slides
double has made to come back before
already nice low parry there good option
yeah I feel like double one of those
players that plays so fast that he's
able to employ you know different
options in different situations
especially when you splash ducky he's
trying to find his opening and right now
he's looking to close out this round and
he probably will yes with the legend
kick so good stop table finally of the
board off the toothpick transuranic in
it probably better for him here since we
don't have any more walls doesn't want
to get caught in the corner like he did
in the first two rounds absolutely
it's a different game now that oh and
again with the downpour - that he was
gonna react that is so great because you
know that Noah can launch that downpours
he's one of the accounts is the cost I
cannot you don't check well that's thing
I mean you got to play at a level where
you cannot get your moves eliminated
from your mu set right yes you got to
still believe it it if you could land it
it's gonna put the other component or go
boating on there just look at that again
that was three one yeah I was three one
I would say even though double ended up
you know having a strong third round
that was still pretty easy I think I was
comfortable yeah yeah what playing it's
jack but we saw have already lose the
first match in a previous match and he
brought it back he's been to come back
hit so far
uh-huh but you know this these points
are important you know double obviously
plays very well here in Pool B but
Anakin you know he wants to be able to
get a significant lead as well he lost
the match earlier you wanna match after
that again super Akuma yes but he does
want to get into the plus and right now
he is games wise but he wants to get the
scent yes if he gets this set right here
he will be tied with super c'mon matches
but with the round count this is a - oh
I think you'll be in effect in the show
so let's see second game he can double
bring it back oh man that was a cleanest
cleanest elbow nice able to get the ball
out there with the shoulder lean get the
back row College Double Dragon hit in
the air so it looks like still some
decent damage though yeah
he is trying to shake his hand that down
Ford one here the left upper this is
what double you know this is a tall man
at down for two perfect timing net
mannequin threads the needle taste the
first job that's a true jack layer like
even on paper he knows he can get
launched yeah he does not care yeah he
will use it because he knows it's gonna
hit he trusts I mean that's the power of
down for to you don't use it to be block
to use it to be hit of course of course
trust in his company download timing
double China's mess to get into that
close right but I think if did such a
good job in fending him off and this
thing is Anakin spacing in his appalled
my gosh I thought he was gonna think
yeah doctor is acting for such a long
time that legislation yeah that's what
they call it right off the wall if he
gets the wall it's close its close I'm
not gonna call anything here my name is
not James I don't think it's I don't
think is dead
alright good call now just out of range
in the wow what a cheeky low kick
they're tied up on rounds here double
miss the punish peaceful - you get the
round so here we go nice step yes so I
step left is the direction you want a
genuine you go first the jacket it beats
a lot of his low options yeah they're
also beats as you know is jackhammer
option as well yeah
so using that is obviously great but I
mean there are a lot of tools that Jack
has and you know some tools that
probably underutilized here in season 3
especially now that his oneplus 2 has
gotten changed to mid at the second here
you can used to be double a notable but
now sent you - Messi and some players
haven't made that adjustment yet where
they duck in the mid part of them yeah
yeah I don't know that's gonna come into
play but it doesn't matter right helped
me topple is rushing down there's the
slide he's gonna slide again know goes
to the mid oh that goes to the mid
option again no puncture the doubt of
the fourth - but it doesn't matter heavy
go double has finally found his range
when it gets into that coast range
listen Jack it makes it very
uncomfortable for him
yeah the range and also the rhythm he's
really taking over whoa the pokes in the
match and look at that point blank with
putty share with the 3+4 as the wall
dragon cannon again you keep it up there
oh man the slides are coming he's doing
what he wants
mark he's doing what he wants you I you
double will even up the sand one match a
piece and it's so great man look he's
done this before
already he loses the first man she looks
like a bit of a blow-up and it brings it
back that's such a sign of a true champ
they get the same stage again yeah well
that's rapidly you'd rather stay there
but right now I mean very strong
showings from both winds and each one of
these players parts but I think doubles
kind of woken up here adapt imitations
need to be made right here right now who
is gonna take this very very important
match for Coco Marquis hoping double
takes this yeah and it's not just about
you know adapting it's about changing
your style and forcing them to adapt
even further
yeah is that gonna happen this is a
pivotal third match this is a deciding
match yeah what's gonna happen here
again starting off with the magic fork
and again trying to find these hits that
he needs all be playing different I can
tell yes he's definitely out in there
for a mission poke it away good break in
the throat he was ready and that's thing
you do not let people get away with that
free mix-up you yeah it's the junkyard
globe Harry you make the papers I feel
like you even delayed a bit boos I think
it was so ready with the loci which is
so good Oh Knights gets the punish here
pushing him closer to the wall what's
gonna do there in the open no jump in
the 4-3 oh you got to be ready for the
Shaolin spin kick from the wall bounce
oh wow this man is brunch and with the
rage will let you kick able to do just
enough damage and look at that double
now with the lead officially here in the
set yes
like I said this would be a really good
position for kukoba
you really want to double to win all of
his matches to put everyone else in a
worse position that second spot is open
it has them at the wall now I want you
to such a solid string nice duck go
there from Anakin the two history of
Washington one two should be close to
death doesn't get the wool though one
more hit will do it but rage available
we would've seen him do really really
sick combat but double not gonna get it
this time Anakin one match a piece one
round of he's hair very close set big
wave force a step to no punishment
double and again these guys now starting
to use jabs trying to play a bit more
compact but right now look at these oh
my god what a whip understand from
anagen range oh you got him looking
yes I do okay nice look sat down for
it's a magical setup down for two now he
has range is he gonna be able to kill
not quite with a down corn wad up one
that once sat point yeah this is
important right now Anakin's gonna have
to make a comeback here he's gonna have
to find what he needs here oh yeah oh
man there again with the wall rising one
- OH
brawl alleged kick pushing him to the
other side of the stage as well he's
kidding himself blocked that thing you
have to feel yourself
look at this damage is looking really
good right now for a double ducks under
the pool - gets the ones that they want
- big pop up that now means that double
is qualified for that top eight yeah and
it now means we're in an even more
sticky situation oh yeah for who's gonna
make it out on the loser side yes this
is gonna be rough
can we hopefully we get a look at the
standing because I want to see where we
are at the moment double with three and
OH at the moment undefeated yeah of
course our lab team is hard at work
crunching the numbers trying to figure
out who's gonna be able to qualify and
what the situations are what the
stipulation is to make sure that we're
able to find out who's gonna make it but
you guys can see the standings right and
there it is this doesn't show of course
actually it does show the game town but
it's it's tough it is tough yeah and it
could run into EPEL the maestro one and
two super Akuma currently in qualifying
position but still more matches to be
played double has one more match I think
it's against super Akuma so super
chemica with that I believe that won't
mean he is through if he if he can yeah
that's the thing
and of course it's it's gonna be rough
either way I mean we have our next
matchup yes getting prepped for the sage
we have Talon Kokomo yes and that win
that double just got I think gives Co
coma and opportunity and maybe I don't
wanna say for sure but there is some
glimmer of hope
yeah for Coco my hair because double has
been winning all of his matches he was
devastated in his last match but he has
another opportunity here you can see
he's got that killer face man but able
to master also in a good position is
anyone for this it's for the taking him
on that top eight spot so much money on
the line as well oh yeah over $250,000
extra 50 grand added in as well last
minute oh man lovey love the biggest sow
prize pool and technical world tour
history that's beautiful absolutely
beautiful here we go it's gonna be Korea
versus Peru what do you think about this
man Eliza Eddie are we gonna see the
area heinous stick with the Eliza I
don't know I think this one's gonna be
tough to call you know he's been using
all eyes at the entire day so far yeah I
think he's been doing all right you know
yeah I think he's probably gonna
continue I I think he's probably gonna
continue but III think I'm more curious
about which character is kokum we're
gonna
uh I'm probably alright I mean he's been
using ball but he's Humphrey Kazumi
right now oh he's going back to Paul
yeah he's going back to Paul he hasn't
no he's thinking hard him uh that's his
thinking face crosstalk did everything
he know he based on the controller's
using he's picking Paul oh yeah
he's picking while you just waiting he's
awaiting confirmation he might just be
thinking about the matchup or thinking
about unplugging his controller and
plugging in the other one yeah it's
interesting just in case you guys don't
know at home yeah
Kokomo depending on the character that
he uses he will use a different type of
controller yes which is a new level of
mastery oh oh he is with you yes can you
imagine how travel with like you know
three different arcade $600 so annoying
it looks like he's gonna be great for
the Dragunov hair then ah that or maybe
the devil gene or the Kazumi I don't
know let's see to see the buttons are
being changed yeah
even even about he hasn't he hasn't
knocked in either I'm gonna have to get
blind fit he's gonna have what I
expected you know he's been practicing
in use it utilizing the character for
the match up so far in right now Kokomo
look at the tension on his face uncover
hi Kazumi as well oh I would love if you
pet Kazumi that'd be so good
his Kazumi has been doing so much work
over the years can it get him out of
this sticky situation or would he go to
dragon off oh man taking his time to
tell them to hurry up we don't have all
day it's it's crunch time man this is it
it's this Now or Never
and he is locked in with dragon off
Sergei dragonov alright dragon off
versus Eliza I bailed the maestro
capable
here of booting Kakuma out of this
tournament once and for all giving
himself an opportunity to qualify so
much to play for here in this group
harue versus Korea with the Mishima dojo
let's get into it all right starting it
off here decent-size States for both of
these characters I'm sure they're able
to get to the wall if they need to my
dragon up can get a world on an infinite
stage yeah that's it that is true then
issue you know that was that wall that
I'll fall breaks he picks one of those
with them underneath under the hot wet
follow up here there's the low swipes
nice able to get it
slight adjustment there it's good seeing
him use the dragon up as long as the
counter that he's gonna be more
comfortable with it's been rocking the
porter have not been working him just
like he said bar here yeah I mean Paul's
one of those characters with if he gets
the hit he's gonna do so much damage
when he's been having trouble getting
those hits right here yeah what about
hits have you got it with a maestro for
the first round
yeah you reach I teach nice
waiting for this opportunity against a
bell really always controlling I feel
like he's been controlling the flow of
the matchups against pretty much
everyone that he's been playing and
forcing them to play his game whether
it's up close folks and then starting to
jump away really creating opportunities
for himself he's been able to use that
as a reactionary peda tactics yeah it's
been his space control which is really
allowed him to be winning just because
you know he'll jump back for example try
to pay out waves user darkwave su-22 so
now his opponents and then go into close
range when he has to to get those down
threes in but it's funny because
historically did dragon of his known as
that character that just controlled
space really well yeah I mean that last
round we saw coke and we're really doing
it with that down to just conjunct it up
down to with some solid bids here is
really what dragon has always been about
right yeah a new season three carriers
all rushing up the wall hair oh yeah
people people eat so much all right
let's see what he does with me he has an
opportunity he has a comeback potential
he has rage as well as a drug combo
what's the adaptation nice oh and a down
to swipe again cocomong looking good
still two bars of soap can swipe all the
monster uses one of them for no avail
nice again continue the pressure cook
was actually looking really really good
in the matchup so [ __ ] has the patience
showing the familiarity at least versus
the character very good stuff to come
out using running - oh yeah right now
does have the light with you'll see what
he does with a poke but starting to
fight back but a good block just in time
there on the dive kick it's got another
bar so they keep coming oh it has to be
careful again snuffing it out he's not
scared of using Tomita he's using it
very liberally man just trying to find
the opening yeah I mean why not every
you have to meet her use it it's a safe
option for him yeah
surprising a lot of players don't try
that power crush go ahead you know
that's true maybe the skirt is getting
washed who knows
okay we got postcards in range 13
seconds that's the clock the running two
hits run up the air and Koba with the
first match yeah
that was good stuff waking up a bit a
bit too late mark but what's going on
here like I don't know I mean we've been
seeing him for the for so many years use
dragon off and you know we said we've
said time and time again that you know
it's not about tears it's about which
character you're most comfortable with
right yeah I think that might be a
problem for players like Kokomo where
they're comfortable with many characters
because he's so fundamentally solid he
can pick up any time you'd like me you
know in a sense as well because he plays
so many cars yeah well he could also
play any controller I mean this guy
five characters to the tournament he
brought six controllers you brought
three outfits guy needs to settle down
man yeah and sometimes it's the
decision-making process that really is
the part that's taxing on you yeah in
retrospect with a bell you know we all
knew that he had two characters but he's
only rocking one he is focused he's
using Eliza through and through that's
what he can start to develop your game
times properly yeah beyond the normal
the normal expectations for your your
play style yeah right now be counting it
and the knife gigs locked and loaded
he's gonna get some distance here oh
it's nice but every calcula every carton
is game god I'm really good more carry
yeah alright poor positioning echo come
on
trying to get Wolves back and ice block
on the downfall put no punish yeah that
wall corner kinda messed up the flow
there yeah Oh fine Abel's gonna tie that
around that won't be the first round
good stuff there unfortunate for
Commodore to Appel is really gonna have
to start turning it up I mean he is down
1-0 right now I think he had a lot of
tough sequences that last matchup as
well yeah you know Kokomo Bruce really
able to control the space with Dragunov
I mean I mean that's a specialty right
using the down to using the mid options
yeah forcing his opponent to to where
all right nice able to convert here
sideways though you have to be careful
down to
oh wow uh-huh
nice he's trying to maneuver his weight
yeah away from the quarter is riffle all
these stages are you know differently
shaped and could coma trying to size
walk out there but he keeps on putting
himself back to the wall but nice guess
on the local cover with a punish as well
one throughout the piece second game
yeah I mean it's nice stuff let me see
the way that I bail plays him I mean
he's not overly using the back - because
he still wants to be in distance to be
able to do something yeah he's using
more of a back walk where he's just
holding back and waiting for an
opportunity funny
drag enough to whip more often than not
oh man there's a launch yeah I don't
have that deep use intentional books a
couple will take full advantage of it
heavy goes hey hey hey
and the delay the follow up here what's
the mix-up oh my gosh you have to be
careful cuz that's gonna hurt did he get
to launch though right so you might get
a comeback here he has a sliver of
LiveCode
oh yes rage what's he gonna do that
could have killed Ray's drunk man would
you use it the town port for keep out
cook Homa perfect now on set point
trying to stay alive here in this world
finals yeah pokemon having a chance
still he is very close gets a big hit
with the crowd just attack once you get
to do it against the wall one things if
you do it well is it what is it kind of
it will make the comeback he's working
on the perfect have you got yang
divekick not gonna be a lot of damage
but it's a start yeah he's great
available he didn't do a lot of damage
either because it got him out of there
but again the down port for closing it
out
yeah pokemon getting another on the
scoreboard this is crazy about this pool
is crazy who is gonna take that second
spot I'm still waiting for the data
Sciences team to kind of tell us where
we're at this is nuts I mean it's it's
it's insane to think again another block
with such intense matches where we don't
know who's gonna qualify it I think
though I believe if I'm doing my quick
map correctly that if that next match is
gonna be very important it is gonna be
crazy super kuma this is you I use
double double is three and OH at the
moment super kuma is two and one if he
wins versus double that will be two guys
at three and one yeah in which would
that and put them in better position
everyone else that would be yeah surely
that would be because don't know no one
none of the other players would be able
to reach 3-1 yeah exactly so this Mac
next match could decide the fate of
everyone super Cooper versus double if
super Kimmel wins double and super Kumar
make it through no pressure yeah so
right no pressure
Anakin kukoba are hoping that's you know
that super can we lose that loses it's
crazy to think because super Akuma in
double though they've been you know
pretty deep in tournaments I mean double
did failed at the LCQ last year right
yes super Koopmans never gonna had a
full play at the world finals for both
of them to have the potential to be able
to make it out is huge it's very big
it's huge it shows their growth of
course as players and of course I forgot
to give a massive shot so I put the
maestro's well he's out of time
unfortunately but you know such a such a
strong player a good great start to to
the to the to the day but couldn't quite
finish yet the sole representative of a
Latin America did such an amazing job to
earth the entire very strong player yeah
I'm kind of sad we didn't it to see is
Eddie but I'm sure we'll see that he in
the future I'll for sure my shots to
Peru and the whole of South America man
you guys are amazing so passionate so
have you got super Akuma this is a big
one this is a big one uh-huh
this could decide it where the French
people I don't is a few you now out
there man where are you honey I lay oh
there we go
they're cheering they're cheering the
chant Pro Cooper I don't even need to I
don't even need to talk to the Japanese
they're gonna make a lot of noise anyway
but yes it could just like you said Bach
it's gonna come down to this man
it's super Cooper wins this he is
through to top eight for the first time
in a World Finals
that's the thing too because you know he
was talking about how he wasn't
confident at the mix-up which was the
first event of the year
yeah and he ended up winning that
tournament he also said just the other
day he's not confident in this
tournament as well yeah now he's on the
verge of making out you know he might be
able to make it on the winter side he
might be able to make it out on the
water side
this is crazy night oh you know Europe
blesses Japan and you know he has had a
lot of practice versus law as well got a
lot of stronger players in Europe but
also he's pending as lohi quite a bit as
well in long sets but this is a
different law player bro this is the law
I would say anyways we're gonna find out
how this one's gonna play out right now
we're in suit stage yeah la la baby all
right they're suiting up sweetie
let's go comes down to this yeah and
again this is probably one of the
storylines for a lot of the players
who's they've been all training against
Akuma at least the past few months
really yeah and super Akuma this kind of
affected his gameplay as well cuz you
know he obviously had to step it up
because people warned more people trying
to learn how to fight against his
character in his play style yeah you
know but he's that de vacas this this
year as well because always funny
obviously coming in and showing the
power of down to and static food he's
learned a lot about how to use the cream
as well so we see the hair as well yeah
like we see the effect of that good
positioning for both of these players so
far yeah about even on my foot Akuma
does does have the advantage with the
rage right now oh there's the low pair
you need a little pair of those you
can't get them use the meter use the
meter
I slipped punished there from double
there Able's goes it out I mean the
thing is the range of that forth more
you have to make sure they at least
block it right it's very interesting to
watch the approach of table head it's
against Tsukuba he's not paying as crazy
as was before I know this PE caught over
except mr. kimitaka toys one down
between there and you're dead yeah
that's things you know he's the way he's
fighting to he's pushing himself into
the range where Akuma would be dangerous
for right now no meter though for Akuma
so yet a little bit extra room to play
around right yeah it could be a little
bit more aggressive
oh nice just the tip pushing towards the
wall here
on your sin library exactly with that
what we're hit nice goes for that one
too and wit punished why double three to
run straight this is what everyone in
the group wants my Anakin
he wants his cook over he wants double
to win yeah here's a follow up he has
the wall here goes with the side splat
gets it let's see the follow up yeah now
the fifty-fifty goes for the mid Oh in
the punish she was ready for it a great
punish oh whiff out of the plan that is
counter it it's dead ones run counter
hey here we go super cuba on the board
now some momentum perhaps that's what
you need man he does have meter as well
though so it is not for a lost cause
yes boom you go be careful man you gotta
be careful double plane is very very
good key pocket does it again it gets a
proper heavy done should be able to get
the whole hair and a dragon cannon combo
nice what's gonna do with it again super
Cooper this I'm running in where he
needs to gets the big damage he's gonna
get the wall oh yes goes for that Tatsu
goes for the mid option as well oh man
he's letting it rip uh-huh dice I don't
know if that was a hole should have gone
for it looks very very crazy I do it the
double special just throw it out the
back for three oh man and you could see
I mean I saw it on the corner of the
screen Super Puma reeled his head back
he was like why did I hit that button
yeah so the thing is doubled likes to do
that we go in the LCQ last year as well
where he got so many people with it just
throw her out the back for three with
the war he super can be interrupted it
with the low jab he should have known
that he was gonna try and do it again
yeah the slightest of back steps and
just boom your life is gone yeah anyways
they're gonna go right to the rematch
super kuma opting to stay with the stage
if double wins this match it opens up
the doors Pandora's box
oh man it's gonna be crazy anyways we're
gonna go right into this again right now
looking really good
you want you stopping to it
look at to make you out in winners at
the top a deafening up so much life
there you want the power first attempt
nice going in you happen to have that
confidence there karate'd combo you have
whoa here we go this is big
yep now one sliver of life left he goes
with the flow into the flip gig tried
that last time and it worked for him so
have you got doubled now with the
momentum alright super Cooper with meter
now so this kind of changes things
let's see what he's able to do how he's
able to utilize the mix-ups here counter
hit when he drops it no that's not good
cut and finish those guys especially in
this kind of situation
yeah such an important one he's able to
easy I mean he's close to building up
another meter again yeah but I mean
double would have been dead by now
exactly Oh be careful he still gets in
the back turn four three closing it out
and now having the beater virtually yes
let's see what he does that's the thing
is you got to be careful you got to
believe in that move but you also got to
be careful they can live in thought by
that right oh boy I thought he just
dashed up it's a low tide it's not
double man's like double follow-up whoa
the jump the jump sometimes the jump if
the pressure is what you need
yeah he's so good with that classic
double head to go seven golden let's set
point now for double to make you out in
winners of Group B open up Pandora's but
here we go
the junkyard County this is the good
part - super cool oh man this is really
is he get a double double all back okay
put the brakes on all the other way okay
opportunity all the shooters here comes
super Akuma he's gonna use the rage art
yeah get it out of the way he has meters
and also he still get the kill it's
gonna come down to the mix up here
what's he gonna do hard boy
okay thanks
thank duffel with a perfect record here
in Group B four-and-oh will make out and
witness a big pop up super cool of
course knowing but that was his
opportunity to make it out of the group
but it's got over yes so great to see
cuz just last year yeah on our world
tour stage we saw double in tears when
could it make it out of the LCQ
but now undefeated the biggest winners
practice item top eight great stuff for
double want to turn around absolutely
man you love to see it but this is the
situation right now super kuma is still
you know sitting up there he's still
able to qualify but it's gonna come down
to Anakin and Kakuma
you know yeah of course again our team
crunching the numbers in the background
letting us know where we're gonna stand
now this is gonna play out but of course
it's all gonna come down to this final
match here it's all on Anakin we've
already kind of figured out that Kokomo
does not have a chance to make it out
but he does have a chance to ruin dreams
is that is that the case I don't know
maybe I won't I guess it depends on on
wins in the amount of games that you get
right well if gonna if Kakuma wins - oh
now you will have a better record than
the other guys then he has a better
record than Anakin so he will make it
him so he'll make it it he has to win
2-0 but if Anakin here wins 2-0 he will
make it in as well
or 2 1 you'll make it in yes so if I can
only needs to win one match it's the
same situation as before right yeah cuz
you'll get 5 I could come a combo we
just let her play out then we'll ask I
wanna know now I'm pretty sure if could
come out with if Anakin wins one match
here in this set then Anakin is through
I think you miss out god damn man
this is this is well of course we will
reconfirm once we get the word from our
team but right now we have to focus on
the match that's ahead of us we have
radiance Red Bull Anakin going up with
his Italian Kokomo USA versus South
Korean you know these guys have played
each other very recently at Dreamhack
Atlanta where Anakin put hands on Kokomo
oh yeah oh really yeah it was a he threw
up the a pretty quickly so yes yeah of
course I don't think any of those guys
are currently out Cuba anakena tomorrow
still
but it comes down to this final match of
Group B yeah and you know when they last
played Kokomo ended up using Paul which
is I mean about a valiant character pick
right you know yeah
knees already shown in the past that
Paul is the character that works against
Anakin but again different character
different player yeah exactly
Jack if we're gonna see what we're gonna
see here he's got a big ball well he's
had before okay that advantage having
Wow Bob ooh okay I mean I'm a
commentator I'm not a player right I
mean we don't know what's going through
his head I mean the pool wasn't working
for today like we said right yeah what's
he gonna do that's uh I don't know he's
locked into costumey he locked in Manny
locked in maybe Anna King was expecting
the poor but the kazumi has come out and
this was a character that gotten so many
wins in previous world tours he's a very
very strong kasumi's so here we go guys
the last match of Group B it all comes
down to this
if Kakuma wins - oh he will be qualified
man so much pressure here so much on the
line yeah you have no choice at all you
got it to it anyways starting it off
here battle it red
all righty trade blows and you know this
is different from what Anakin faced when
they played again recently because you
know obviously as I mentioned he used
Paul and Anakin was able to overcome
that rather easily but now having to
deal with I guess a character with a bit
more options tool wise yeah oh sorry
more I gotta say you know Anakin has
played kokum in the patterns against his
Kazumi and he's able to was able to beat
them Anakin trapper record against
Kokomo is actually pretty good right
well come looking good right now but the
round is not over yet nice with whip on
the down back one but no punch on KO
coma
one more hit will do it he's taking his
time though doesn't want to overcommit
nice keeping it simple one wonderful
thumb over the first round how crazy
would it be to it could come after
that's that really terrible start
manages to make it in okay we've been
told from our data Sciences team now
whoever wins the set will make it out
score design man oh boy that is the that
is the tale of the tape right now so it
is a true elimination match he's crazy
nice and Kokomo right now able to get
the throw it's the wall stunt the follow
up here not gonna kill but we have a mix
of opportunity and it can having a rage
now so he's gonna do more damage I think
it need to get out of that as soon as
possible you going to be in the corner
I mean sometimes people like to be the
cornered beasts right they want to feel
that pressure it forces their opponent
coming towards them to Round Top yeah it
was a very slow play two rounds but he
was able to pull it out yeah here we go
Anakin again chopping away with the lows
starting it off like usually does about
threading the needle that with one one
to perfect is any paper the jackhammer
comes in guarantee few spots
Anakin fighting back and that's the
thing that's the even though we know the
weakness of the jackhammer and many
people know what it is Anakin's
confidence in using utilizing at who is
unchanged he will use it whenever he has
the opportunity right
okay follow up here Anika with a slight
lead here but you cannot neglect the
fact that she is flashing red oh yeah
good stuff from Anakin so consistent
with abuse bucks free complicated input
as well fees always able to do it yeah
the Megaton upper is something you have
to rely on especially what you have it's
guaranteed nature for the most part I
mean I mean yeah you know there's a
spring kick option to get out of it but
there are other options on top of that
there's different layers on top of the
mind game on how characters can escape
the following I'm sitting and this thing
is like you you want to feel like you're
cool that you escaped it but then you
get launched again that's like the worst
feeling mmm-hmm anyways back at it these
guys about even on life here to co-op in
such a slow game right now he has him in
this is his tournament year riding on
this matchup right now that was huge
this is gonna be a ton of damage once
you do he's gonna cash out no he's going
for the mix-up what is it there's not
long left 15 seconds only oh there's the
punish he got he got him nice and I can
take all the final round
yowzers are we gonna get an American in
the top eight confirmed
again the follow-up here look at the
damage shut up any kids looking really
good
okay he gets the ball sending for and
that's a big food that hurts
yes size 28 boot size 20 28 man it's a
big one
big quick on the board 41 no punishment
for coma
nice big counter hit the fall of Annie
can do in here all night shining fist
combo ooh
swipes away at the low be careful all in
the parties you commit the three again
and an acute with a damaged one that was
a robust we mannequin three around
straight if he wins the next match you
will be qualified for that top eight and
again if you guys are tuning in right
now you guys are watching group reaction
this is the final match of group II it's
come down to anakena Kokomo the winner
of this set will qualify in the losers
side mmm for our topping which will be
played later on today and double made it
through in the winners side as well with
a perfect for our record there we go
he's sticking with the kazumi mom
sticking with the kazumi
he's gonna let it ride I mean that is
his character that is the character he
dressed up as he is one with his
character it was fate
all right brimstone and fire it's gonna
come down to this day we'll have walls
all around yep
but it's on an aquiline right now he is
on a vacation point yeah yeah let's see
what he does with it fine
currently we have two Koreans in our top
eight for pool a Osan and me will that
be another one put into that pressure
nice - who forward caught up sleeping on
the ground right now lively in favor of
Anakin but Kokomo you get caught about
he has rage he ended up using the range
drive and used it immediately this is
scary cuz I think it is starting to - in
with these bits or big risky they're
from Kokomo the trade still anyone's
match
the standing - so much pressure here oh
you just see the heart breaking into
little pieces there as it gets blocked
yeah that was gonna be for the winds
Anakin knew that can have to block yet
good stuff here
Hayes the first round two rounds away
from qualifying for this topic running
to again here's the pressure stature
kick and look at this coconut looking
really good right now looking to turn
things around because you know we still
have the chance
seven golden letters say so the best way
to on sit back fight alright
and again just mixing up the time here
even will end that big jackhammer now
pushing against towards the wall but a
big blow parry oh honey yo he's gonna
get this wall damage he's gonna put the
hurt here's the mix of bread stuff get
out of there Kokomo that's not where you
want to be and it can walk round away
for qualifying for the Tekken World Tour
Finals top eight in the loser site
banana keenest looking on fire right now
runs up hits it down for it to Noah
Kokomo will probably try to sidestep and
look she's looking so good right now
look at this pressure who goes through
the press doesn't mind getting hit by
that this is it Mike
this meant where you wanna be feel
kurková he has range available go get
out of the wall yeah those are great
side steps but man is it too little too
late he's gonna have to really put it
together here I think in Chinon back now
waiting waiting for the bus
and again just harassing them with the
jackhammer hmm that annoying sound you
hear outside your hotel window pic with
the punish them oh man there it is
radiance redbull Anakin will make it
through and Kakuma is eliminated what an
amazing group man but come of course not
gonna be happy he was so close so close
but Anakin just to solid on the diamond
yeah a tough year for both of these
players of course it's gonna be
emotional
whenever you get some part at this level
where you're playing against some of the
best players in the world you have to
believe in yourself and sometimes
there's gonna be those heartbreaking
moments we've seen it you're in and
you're out
but of course congratulations to both
double and Anakin qualifying for our top
eight yeah but give it up for super
Cooper I could come as well they fought
really really well and not gonna be able
to make your part which I'm sure we'll
see a lot more of them in the future
yeah that was rough that was rough I
mean it was a situation where a super
Akuma was like literally one match away
from qualifying then in the we just saw
another match where kokumo was one match
away from qualifying but this is how it
went down man double with four and oh
four wins undefeated Anakin I mean it
was tough super cool man and I came tied
down and it can had more wins yeah and I
gotta take the players I mean the
players are really what make up the
world tour you know super Akuma Kokomo
able I mean even neuroma Arslan and
shadow from the previous pool these guys
have put together some amazing stories
throughout the entire year yeah and it's
all thanks to them that Tekken was able
to grow even more so year over year
absolutely man absolute it's been
amazing the diversity has been the main
story of this it's just been a great
year at second man but guys do not go
anywhere because this is this is only
pools man this is all these pools in
before we get into our next break and we
switch up to pool see I want to give a
shout out of course to our lovely
sponsors Quan ba official Joystiq
partner of the Tekken World Tour right
now they have a special promotion on
their website farmer usa.com you can
take advantage of this awesome backpack
in obsidian combo and of course the
drone as well check them out at Quan by
usa.com yeah
premium fights takes right there but get
your hands on one of those but yes when
we return we will be back with some more
pool action and it's gonna be a crazy
one if it's anything like the last two
so do not go anywhere we'll be right
back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]